oh good morning welcome to Tokyo today
we're going to go to comic aura which is
a place of some Tokyo used to be the
capital but now it's just a place people
go on a busy I'm out of breath are we
gonna go shopping a little bit but your
brother coming along so let's go up MA
hey this corner main lights forever
we're going to the train station and
it's gonna be amazing
a little bit I'm so excited I got all
the tourists I'm not the only tourist
massabi
mm I'm feeling a bit sick I'm worried
because oh my god I got to take a
lifetime in Tokyo
and what made me not sick was running
for instance
you better work we're in Kamakura we're
gonna go and rent a bicycle and just go
around to explore I'm scared that we're
gonna die we're going to coat the Korean
temple and it's about 15 minutes we did
it
I can't believe it that looks awesome
dem nips yeah oh my god there's the
Buddha there it is Wow incredible so I
used to be a temple around this that
burned down I got destroyed whenever so
cool Fanta melon soda
I look oh my god they pour it down for
you oh my god nice chemicals apparently
Obama was here first
dammit I want to take a swim
there are pretty good waves I really
want to swim I don't know why let me
touch the water oh my god
it smells so nice I know what this smell
is but it's so good I like spicy
homeless we're going to a shrine now
hopefully we don't get lost I don't I
think we will
crazy uphill better be worth it
oh my god I don't know what that is oh
you go through oh my god that's awesome
oh my god okay we're going in so I know
if you can see me this is so weird
we found it Wow shutter bang this is my
kind of candy we're finally going back
taken by a train back to Tokyo Frank I'm
really tired we got lost again
and I feel kind of sick now I did it I
did it again got sick in Japan again oh
my God look at this bed things are gonna
happen a lot of sleeping I'm so tired
all right look it lives so they have all
these but logos so this is butt spray
give me some buy spray baby what's your
name Lisa out Lisa okay let's see I did
something let's try the spray Oh
something just touched my boy oh sorry
welcome I mean good morning I'm I'm sick
today stupid country hates me
why we're going back with the plane is
in a couple hours so I'm done I hope
you're happy
there's someone I need to say goodbye to
Lisa what are you leaving me no sorry
Lisa I gotta go back to Sweden I mean UK
but pay me love you I can't look more
here do you
we're going to London now be my best
friend
how's it going and I don't even know I
feel I feel better but I took so much
medicine where's my demon hey gay hey
gay it's me hey oh my god hey hey yeah
hey hey hey hey you have returned yes
back home yeah I can sit in my chair all
day now thank you and I won't get sick
oh my god I I feel so bad but it was an
amazing trip really thanks so much -
square-enix Andina for for taking me
there and showing me their next game I'm
very excited for it even though I got
sick totally worth it I just finished
editing these videos you're welcome but
that's it for now please live like you
know I didn't want to see more vlogs
like this I would love to go and more
adventures for your breasts that's
that's it for now I will see you pros in
the next one stay